Pods can be created using
pod configuration files.
Let's take a moment to explore
the model of pod configuration file.
There are a few things to notice here,
you'll see that our pod is made up
of one container, the monolith.
You can also see that we're passing
a few arguments to the container
when it starts up.
Lastly, we're open up port 80 for
HTTP traffic, and
port 81 for our health checks.
Create the monolith pod using kubectl.
Let's examine our pods.
We'll use a kubectl get pods command
to list all the pods running in
the default namespace.
It may take a few seconds before
the monolith pod is up and
running, as a monolith
container image needs to be
pulled from the doca hub
before we can run it.
Used the kubectl describe command to get
more information about the monolith pod.
You'll see a lot of information
about the monolith pod,
including the product IP address and
the event log.
This information will come in
handy when troubleshooting.
As you can see kubernetes makes it easy
to create pods by describing them in
configuration pods and
viewing information about
them while they're running.
At this point you have the ability to
create all the pods your deployment
requires.